so high I hope everyone is having a
really great afternoon so I currently
work at automatic which is a company
behind wordpress com amongst other
things and I have this thread of
psychology running through my life
studies and career and code psychology
really really excites me and I love
doing experiments and I love trying to
work out how we can actually create
experiences that connect with others
that really really drives me so emotion
is a really really powerful thing it
drives us to actions it makes us feel
connected and kind of it's an essential
part of being human in one day we can
laugh we can cry and weaken sigh and our
range of emotions is incredible our face
and body show these despite quite often
trying to hide them we also have this
desire to associate emotions to
inanimate objects and it's something we
all do so my laptop for example if it's
not booting it's sad it's feeling grumpy
I associate those emotions with it and
if it works expected it's happy it's
having a great day and that's part of
the nature as humans we expect things to
have emotions and we all just demand it
because without it we kind of feel a
little bit uneasy and pics are actually
recognize this in their first official
short film called luxo jr. and in this
film there's a little lamp which plays
while the big lamp looks on it's kind of
a father and son short in the form of
lamps and animals feel emotions too for
example look the sheer joy of this dog
running we get comfort in this kind of
cycle of emotion so
we recognize joy and then that feeds
back into our joy and this is pepper so
pepper actually is a humanoid robot
designed to live with humans but it's
not task-based pepper actually is a
social robot designed to live
autonomously and to converse recognize
and react to your emotions and beyond
being super super cute pepper actually
as an illustration of how we connect
through emotion an emotional companion
is actually a perfect fit and because I
like robots I like to show another one
for you today and this is power this is
actually a therapeutic robot baby harp
seal and this is designed by intention
to be cute and it's to have a calming
effect and emotional response in
patients of hospitals and nursing homes
so it's kind of the animal version of at
the robot version of animal-assisted
therapy power actually has tactile
sensors across his body that responds to
petting and it can stimulate such
emotions as surprise happiness and anger
and it also has sound similar to the
baby harp seal as well as a sleep and
awake cycle so we connect with it humans
need we need emotional responses that
connection I kind of think we're a
little bit like the primate needing a
hug the world is a scary place and we
need that connection we have a range of
emotions and by understanding emotions
in others we then relate to them samosas
actually are the feelings of the mind
just like physiological sensations an
emotion actually has three components
these are physiological changes such as
increased heart rate behavioral response
such as whether you stay or escape and
as subjective experience like feeling
angry happy or sad and the latter is
normally what we associate with being an
emotion
animation is four years touch the hearts
of us from picture to studio ghibli we
fallen in love with characters had a
heart broken by ink and
computer-generated images animation
connects on a level that touches the
very human heart of us we dive into
those animated worlds and we often
escape into them as well studio ghibli
to me show mastery in each of their
films as far as bringing a sense of
delight goes this is actually an advert
they did so this cat we can relate to
because it's beyond cute right there's a
sense of delight in its playful batting
of the butterfly it's delightful to
watch and it fills you with joy well
mrs. a complete contrast the web it's
never been very good over late interest
as a human interactions often cold clin
clinical because it's not actually a
pixar film and it has in the past felt
like the web was created for robots
rather than humans when you only have an
interface how do you actually show
emotion animation takes advantage of
facial features because robots even have
them right we show our motion on our
faces but what happens when you have no
face so anime and manga actually have a
unique visual language that conveys
character emotion and these range from
speed lines to cryin and something at
racal cat mouths it's a bit of an aside
but i'd like to share this with you a
cat mouth is actually when a mouth gross
finds and looks like a cat and what it
means is the character is feeling catty
so it adds a nerve element beyond the
facial expression to the animation and
to us our understanding of the character
so a lot of you probably know the book
by disney called the illusion of life
disney animation
and in that it set trial basic
principles of animation and these kind
of create illusion that the object
adheres to the laws of physics but it
actually goes beyond that too emotional
timing and character appeal and I feel
when dealing with motion we can probably
deal this kind of reduce the 12 down to
four and those i'd like to share to that
so the first of these would be
anticipation anticipation prepares for
an action this also focuses attention on
an object this could be really useful to
show a start of an emotional response or
arresting emotion and then we have
timing and this is critical for
conveying emotions and different
emotions have different times as well it
really can convey the character's
personality and then we have
exaggeration this is a little bit of a
double-edged sword because it can be a
technique that's actually overused but
where motion is concerned some are
actually exaggerated and this is one
that you can really play around with and
create an emotion in a static element
and then you have appeal which is
essential for motion we have to find
something appealing so this is kind of
if you ever played a kind of D&D this
was your charisma kind of amount in that
so we have less of this then you
wouldn't simplify so in Disney terms
this would be kind of the villain you
wouldn't want to sympathize with the
villain and this is also seen as a
captivation of a character summation
experiences connect with the user they
bring moments of delight an interface
can touch you as you interact with it
and when you do that you actually create
a meaningful in connection and that's
priceless this is how your users become
really really engaged they create
feelings with your interface and in a
sort of way they're kind of bond with it
as a result their investment increases
as they use it so when thinking about
emotion I really think you can learn a
lot from apps and I like to share a few
today so this is katina and in this this
little face look at them as you kind of
interact their eyes and you get that
kind of feedback you relate and you get
that kind of interaction a monument
valley I think can teach an awful lot
about atmosphere and every single
interaction layering up to create an
emotional response and a feeling of the
world an up coffee shows emotion is it
adds up so it kind of gets more and more
and then it's kind of this whoa kind of
as it fills up its so excited to be full
and I couldn't not show flappy bird
because the flappy bird to me shows
personality right from the start so kind
of it unload the little captures ready
to go and to die horribly but it's ready
to go and then it refreshes again ready
to go and die horribly again so we have
this ability to create the same animated
emotion in CSS since animations really
exciting to me and the potential is
thrilling and there were tons of
experiments like this amazing dozing
bird but what about the big of you what
about crane an entire experience in CSS
the sites we create we should see as a
chance to move the user maybe it's for a
reason like this site which we're going
to dr appt showing this we're going to
have the demo from this tonight what
reason touching someone on an emotional
level is powerful in the past if you
wanted to connect with someone with the
same power animation does you use flash
or video this is moving it's making a
real connection with the human as you
use it and this site is how a simple
button connects you with the rest of the
animation on the site I think at this
button had a noise it will kind of be
boring because that's what this button
does as you interact with it and it adds
to the character and the feelings that
unites with those UI elements to create
the entire experience and knowing the
voice of your site and the brand is
really
a foundation to know what to kind of
emotion you want to revoke and it sets
your emotional tone if you think bats
Monument Valley how everything layers up
to create that emotional tone those
examples are great but they're big
they're showcases it's what an entire
animated experience can be and summer
just experiments to test the boundaries
of this relatively new format what about
smaller interactions how can we bring a
sense of delight to those so animation
isn't just for Co pens or fancy
animation flourishes we should be adding
it to the smallest of a UI how do we
take those exaggerations into smaller
forms so like all the examples before
when animation designs for motion is
thought of it tends to be in the sense
of that entire experience the lead role
but these large expenses are incredible
but look at this house lack uses the
emoji pecker that tiny little
interaction that you may hear connection
with that doesn't have to be big and
cold pen I'm not going to play this is
quite a long animation however the
cocaine button is a great attention
grabber because it has different levels
so there's initial kind of wobble and
then it kind of gets more and then if
you really don't notice that it sends a
notification box in so to me the
personality of this is it kind of tries
to kind of make a little cough tries to
get your attention then it kind of
shouts a bit and then it gives up and
calls its mate notification box in and
here's Co pen again I had to share this
because copán just has some really nice
tiny flourishes this heart unload
there's a kind of pulse and then when
you click it it's kind of like you give
your heart away that's a really powerful
and simple thing to do as you like
something and what's better than having
toggles kiddie toggles I love this
because it actually shows how you can
simply add to previously pouring
standard interface something really fun
and interactive and doesn't always have
to be cute but it's kind of nice
when it is and I just loves you change
from no to yes on this so I decided to
conduct a bit of an experiment cuz i
kind of like doing experiments how can I
convey an emotion through simple buttons
animation so I set myself a task to have
a series of buttons with various
emotions and then do a few tests to see
if people got the right emotion so first
of all trying to pick what emotion was a
little bit tricky I knew I wanted some
obvious ones but I also because maybe
I'm odd i want to give myself a bit of a
challenge so I decided unhappy and angry
and then the challenge would be sad
throughout of all good tests I needed to
set some conditions to really try and
get this way and I wanted to kind of
narrow down what I was doing because
there's an awful lot you can do have
animation as an awful lot that can cause
bias and someone when they're
interacting so I decided to just use
ease in and out just use translates and
also to focus on purely just doing
simple keyframes I actually wanted to
kind of get to the lowest denominator
and also want to try and make the button
emotionless in its design because as we
all know people are influenced by color
shape all these kind of other things I
want to try and focus on how the
animation could create the design that
the actual motion so I started first of
all was happy and as with all good
searches I started with animated gifts
and I actually found I'm not sure if
this is a hamster or guinea pig or
gerbil but this small furry happy thing
I found and to me this happy dance just
personify just made me feel happy as
soon as I saw it but I kind of thought I
could go happier than that so I thought
about minions because minions just exude
they just have such happiness it just
kind of is exploding for them as they're
bouncing up and down so I wanted to
bring that into my button so I started
to think how the keyframes would look
and I did some really rough graphs
however this was me just time
think how it would kind of peak and
trough so I kind of thought the happy
button would actually be keen to be used
if you think of the minions they're just
not kind of just grinning that just kind
of can't stop it escaping they're
bouncing so I wanted this button to
actually react on load imagine it'd kind
of be so happy it just couldn't help
itself so little happiness blips were
escaping and then when you actually
interacted with it it will get even
happier so this is a happy button it's
kind of just kind of doing a little and
then when you interact with it it just
cannot escape so this is my version of a
minions in a bun so then I went back to
look at angry and I started think about
how the angry button would appear and i
found this animated gif and you can see
the rock side by side of sheer anger and
i thought this would be good to reflect
particularly in relation to the minion
button with the kind of up and down
movement so i went back to drawing rough
graphs and i kind of thought that I
wanted to attach a personality this time
to its button beyond just kind of the
minion I wanted to actually make you
feel that there was a kind of a girl and
a violent shaking so I actually thought
it would be a little bit like poking
someone awake so it'd kind of be all
quiet and then it'd kind of be a girl
get off is what I wanted this the kind
of anger so you kind of get that feeling
and this is what I had with angry button
so you interact to kind of get off and
it kind of gives that feedback and then
it kind of a second so sad but and I
knew just going to be a bit of a
challenge because sadness is quite a
wide range and it's quite hard to convey
and one person sad really isn't another
person's sadness I did a bit of search
and I found this heartbreaking Pikachu
this kind of all the sad I can't watch
it for too long because it's just too
sad however this to me conveyed the
little trembling I just like that's just
a universal for
so I then thought about how that I would
actually look in a graph and it's kind
of quite you can see the difference in
the emotion in the grass I'm creating
and I thought this is kind of be a
reluctant button and I cited think of
how it'd almost be that sad sighing and
this would be on click and it would be
kind of reluctant there would be this
kind of time delay when we're going back
to timing this really would come into
play with sadness so sad Burton is
actually really sad it's actually quite
a slight emotion but you interact its
kind of that's what the button does so I
then went on to test on some humans I
did five initial 121 test because I just
wanted to see whether i was crazy
developing these buttons by myself
wherever I was actually conveying these
emotions I used cope n to share and I
asked a simple question of what emotion
does this button feel and I really want
to do some more after this if I wanted
kind of a baseline by asking and then
refining and with that I actually
presented three emotions to the person
and ask them to select them and the
reason I did this was you could get five
hugging in lots of different words for
the same emotion I wanted to really try
and pin it down at least initially so
his results happy Burton got five people
which I was really pleased about also
the feedback I got was really
interesting considering I base that on
minions which people said it was rushed
excited and anxious anxious was
interesting but anxious can actually be
very close to excitable happiness so
that was kind of on the money with what
was said in an angry button or five
people definitely said that button was
angry and also what was interesting
relating to the kind of girl get off
people also said it was annoyed so it
kind of was giving that feeling this is
where I got a bit tricky sad Burton all
five people did say it was sad however
people actually
you were saying if I have to pick one
it'll be sad so I don't I sad button was
not a success and I knew this was going
to be hard to sads actually some things
that's really difficult to convey and
the feedback was quite varied such as it
was stoned it was sleepy reluctant and
bored maybe that kind of applies to the
same but it kind of indicates I really
wasn't on the hannah on target foot
being sad and one of the feedbacks I
actually got was that happy and angry
reminded them of their kid which to me
was great considering I based on a
minion and that kind of girl get off
kind of childish thing so that's a fun
experiment I like doing things like that
and I want to do more of those emotions
because to me it was really a useful
experiment how can you actually take
that into the interfaces you create how
can we take that beyond those kind of
cute angry experiments for buttons so
invisible animation can be said to be
the one that creates the most profound
emotions well animation is good you
don't notice that and a lot of the
experiments I'm doing focus on smaller
elements thats aligned this it's also
about adding to the experience and
causing reaction that subconscious if
you think about Monument Valley again i
keep on going back to it because it
layers up to create that experience it's
what animation film students what Pixar
do it's what you do Ghibli do they add
these layers to create the whole entire
experience and that's what we can be
doing the smaller elements so I did a
couple more experiments that I'd like to
share at the end of this talk with you
and one of those scoffing buttons so
this is I was trying to play around with
how I could take a subtle emotion into a
simple interface so what's the coffin
bone it's quite simply in the form of a
button so it's may be very English noise
but it's basically doing that it's not
loud it's so but it's just enough to
grab attention
and this is my version of a coughing
button so it's kind of just in the
corner I want to play around with this a
little bit more it's just my first stab
at coughing buttons but it shows how you
can just have a simple attention grabber
and the other thing I've side a look at
phone calls n inputs and this is really
really subtle it's part of that layering
and adding two different things to how
even an input could be just SAT there
adding to that atmosphere the simple is
quietly waiting that's why it's called
Zen it's just quietly doing its own
thing and you're not meant to notice it
until you interact and it stops moving
that's when you probably notice it don't
know how this is going to convey on the
big screen but it's just ever ever so
slightly making a little bit of movement
and I almost wanted you to not notice it
was moving but kind of register it's
moving so you kind of get that feeling
but you you don't know so all these
experiments are great and fun to do well
for me there but a lot of them come down
to feedback this is when the user
interacts and gets an emotion back it's
the same thing that we relate to the
robots we get that emotional feedback
back while we relate to animals we get
that feedback as well for example if you
click a button and you make it Angry or
if you add input into a field and make
it hold its breath as you do that
feedback isn't the only way to show
emotion through CSS but it can be really
really effective one and quite a low
entry point humans we seek that
emotional feedback and this is a great
way that we can interact through CSS
animation we can bring personality to
interactions buttons can be impatient or
happy a sliding panel might be eager to
actually be opened I'm input field might
be impatient to have content added to it
motion is powerful and we can really use
it to connect to users motion makes
interfaces more human
and as humans we then connect with that
cleaner interface you feel connected to
is incredibly powerful maybe it's a
grand showcase that tugs at the
heartstrings but we should be also
looking at the smaller details and I
hope I've shown that today since this is
really really powerful and we can bring
a little bit of emotion to any aspect
the interface so thank you so much
listening to me I'm going to be around
all day so please come and say hi as I
love meeting new people and I'd be happy
to answer any questions thank you